The Joe Rogan experience was a bad motherfucker.
Very bad motherfucker.
He barely made any lemons.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean,
think about the shitty movies I,
Paul Newman made.
I really can't.
I can't come up with one.
You know,
I can't come up with.
I'm not familiar enough with his entire catalog.
I remember stallone did the comedy movie with his mother.
Oh,
it was a throw momma from the train.
Was that it was another one?
No,
no,
no.
This was um,
what was it called?
A.
This is going to drive me fucking nuts.
I'm.
Oh,
it wasn't at the same woman that was in golden girls that played the old woman,
but she had brown hair.
Oh,
this is going to drive me nuts.
I don't know your Old Lady Trivia.
How do you know that?
I don't know.
It seems like I remember it.
Well.
Let's just look up.
Still owns the loan listening
Oscar.
It was,
it was asking.
Oscar was one.
Let's see.
That's the one that I'm thinking of.
Yeah.
Well he definitely had one called Oscar.
That's the one I was thinking you were thinking fuckers done mama from the
train,
but it wasn't thermometer from trying to throw my of a train.
Was that old gross lady from like goonies or something like that?
Oh,
the fatality.
My mom will shoot stop where my mom was.
So he did two comedies in a row.
He did Oscar and then he did stop or my mom will shoot.
That's how retarded people were in the nineties though.
Like you know what?
Forget all these great comedians we have.
We need to get the loan up there.
They just kept giving them money.
My Old Lady Trivia,
look at this.
It was the old lady Estelle Getty from older girls with brown hair.
That's so crazy.
And look at him.
He's like,
I can't believe.
What are you doing with that gun
for a second?
Look at the look on his face,
man.
Can't believe this.
Look a little my gun it or has it been confirmed and or,
or like,
like completely confirmed that he actually started out doing porn is because
that's.
Yeah,
he did a movie and it wasn't like it was softcore.
so he wasn't like laying pipe on film or anything,
so it might've been,
might've been laying pipe,
but I'm pretty sure they didn't show it if he was,
I think it was like an angle thing and they wanted to sell it to them for a
million dollars.
It was like,
it wouldn't give you 10 sensitive business shifts.
Budget.
Yeah.
Well that's that same thing man.
That's that thing of like wanting to win.
Like I was.
I went to eat dinner at this bar and I was sitting next to this lady and you
know,
like sometimes you're sitting next to somebody and you can tell they have some.
They,
they,
they're,
they're having a problem in life or something.
You,
you either kind of looking for help.
Sometimes you get around people and you can just feel it.
They,
they're lost or they want something and like I'm just sitting there eating and
she starts talking to me.
Right.
And then right away she's goes into talking about how her sister was getting
married and her sister invited her up to big Sur to go to the wedding and got
there.
And there was nowhere to stay and her sister,
her steps or her sister in law is a bitch.
That was the story she was telling.
But when you're looking at someone who's like caught,
that's just one little piece of the puzzle for them.
They're locked into this world view of fighting.
They're constantly on the offensive trying to like poke back at the world and
that's the one little symbol of the thing that she could,
she could give me.
But then she said something shitty to the bartender and then she like said
something shitty to somebody else.
You realize like,
oh,
this person just going through the world trying to shake every living part of
the world.
She wants to cut and Shank and hurt.
She's shut down.
But inside of her,
because that's what I recognize.
I'm like,
shit,
this is like an.
Sometimes the cruelest sort of person is someone who started off trying to be
nice and then got shut down for being nice sometimes.
Yeah.
And I could see all this used to be a very sweet,
nice person.
So I said to her,
you know what?
You should start doing,
you should start doing service work or missionary work and she's like,
I used to do that.
I spent years doing that and she was,
it was like I could see that part of her,
you know,
and then I could see she thought that by doing good things in the world,
she should get some reward for it,
but instead of getting a reward for it,
she got hurt,
whatever it was that happened during the course of her serving the universe,
she got less of what she wanted or didn't get what she expected and because of
that,
she's like,
fuck it,
I'm going to be a bitch from now on because I tried to be good and I got
punished for it.
My wife has a friend that's religious and her and her friend,
her and this other friend were going to.
This woman in her other friend were going to get like a real estate license and
she didn't get it and she passed.
She failed her test,
but her friend passed and she was complaining about it and the what she was
complaining about.
She goes,
I don't get it.
I'm a good person.
Yes,
why didn't?
Why didn't God hook me up with this?
And she literally said that.
That's it right there.
See,
that is the great fallacy of being a good person is the moment you start doing
it,
being a good person,
as a job,
and you're supposed to get these fortune paychecks from the universe in the form
of luck or good things coming to you.
That's the moment you fail.
You fail.
You really have to resign yourself to the idea that mostly if you're being nice
to people,
they're going to hurt you.
First of all,
there's an unbelievable amount of pressure as an artist after not having a show
in four years to,
you know,
every time I do a show I want it to be the best show I've ever done and this was
like such a small amount of time to put that much art together that I was,
you know,
everyone's like,
you fucking bitches in Mexico.
I'm like,
I'm working.
I'm not.
I didn't go to Mexico to fuck you know,
but you have a very strange way of,
fuck.
How do I say it's very bold.
Oh really?
It's like bravado to it.
Like you're wearing a cape.
I didn't go to Mexico to like,
you're confident way saying,
fuck,
why do I,
what do I like to do?
Fuck.
Just like,
it's like you're almost defiant in your tone.
So I got to tell you what happened.
I,
uh,
you know,
because every.
I'm going to go off subject just for a second because no way.
Every time on the show,
every time I think,
wow,
I've experienced a new sexual thing that I've never like,
this is insane.
Like how many are left when a girl's shoots the ice cube?
My butthole or,
or,
you know,
like,
or like when I'm laying down and then like five women or just giving me a
massage,
just using their tongues.
I'm like five.
It's not going to get better than this.
You know,
like this is like,
he doesn't like a baller.
Damn.
I didn't even know who it went to over two handed.
I thought it just stopped there.
You'd have five.
And then.
So I meet a guy yesterday and he's like,
Oh yeah,
we did some red rope shit and this and that,
and I'm like,
I'm like,
I don't,
I don't know what that is,
is like you don't know what a red rope services.
And I go,
no,
but please tell me like,
what the fuck are you talking about right now?
My name is Marty and I'm the inventor of the red rope service.
So honestly sitting there.
Okay.
So you're laying on your bitsa massage parlor.
You Go,
it's a service.
It's not the name of a place,
like a code word you can we get.
Can I get the red rope?
Okay.
So you're getting a massage and I think it's only an Asia and you're laying on
your back and then you go,
you know,
you get the,
you get to the happy ending point where she gets her dick hard and everything
and you're like,
I would like the red rope at this point.
She ties a rope and here's the crazy part.
It doesn't have to be read,
it's just the rope and they tie it to the whatever.
The bars above the massage table and they hook their feet on it so they're
upside down and so they start spinning around and then they put their mouth on
your hard Dick and then they let go and they helicopter their mouth around your
Dick all the way.
And I'd never done it before,
but the guy says it feels like your Dick's going to like,
you've never felt anything like that before in your life.
And it feels like your Dick is just going to explode with a,
you know,
like a neutron bomb,
the explosion and then you.
And then it's done and it stops.
And then it spins the other way around to listen to the crafty.
Always unbelievable because they,
they really like take sex to another level.
Like they try to figure out the most pleasurable things to do to you and then
they do them.
You know,
you're a fucking human being.